what an awesome [ __ ] uh day a wedding
is i did not understand it i know i had
one and i feel like a complete
narcissist in saying that but like no
you don't get it yeah you don't get it
because it's not it's not even just all
the attention it's all the people you
love and she loves in one place together
and you're all just loving each other
yeah it's [ __ ] it's incredible man
yeah it is the best day of your life
until you have kids i assume yeah i i
would agree with that 100 like it was
crazy dude like
yeah and everything that you guys said
about it came true and i tried to do
things that you guys advise like uh
mark said something he's like yo just
like take a moment to like have with
your girl and i don't know if it was you
that said this or that or you said this
they're like when you're up there doing
the vows look out
was it you said that yeah yeah and i and
i made sure that i did that and it's
really cool because it's all the people
that you love in your life right you're
looking at them notice you were behind
me all the people that you love
in your life you're looking at them
without the person that you hate the
most because he's just [ __ ] sat there
sucking up oxygen for no [ __ ] reason
are you going to give him a gift are you
going to
regret
that was his banger that was his banger
right no no he did you have other ships
i had other beggars did i have other
beggars you had some bangers dude can i
talk about me right now
you're a great ted no i'm not he did
great real time did it he did a great
job he did awesome
it was really well done andrew's vows
holy [ __ ] wow yeah unbelievable
and i see you do comedy at an incredibly
high level i have never been more
impressed with you
in that moment well i'll take that yeah
he's taking away his bride shine on on
her most important day that's what he
did
guys
guys there can only be one star
my man is a tough follower
she buried the headliners
she told me she's like i want you to go
first i was like okay
not to get buried
[Laughter]
no no i i honestly um
those were hard did you guys feel this
way like it was it was very hard to
write did you guys i know that we don't
gotta write it but did you guys do
something like uh for each other or
anything like that like yeah like we had
to do like notes before like we gave
them to each other at dinner i remember
you telling me that yeah and was that
difficult for you to like sum up your
entire love and relationship yeah i
didn't try to i was like there's too
much to say
so like here's just kind of how i feel
right now but like just know that i'm
not going to try to summarize it's
overwhelming yeah he's like
i went through the same feeling like
leading up to it i mean i was up to like
three in the morning the [ __ ] night
before like
with a month out i was like you know
what i'm gonna be able to write some
vows and my girl had written hers like
way before and she was like sharing them
with like i think dove and some other
people and they were like yo bro you got
to come correct
and the last thing i want is on our
wedding day
people to think that i don't love my
girl
when she's professing
all this love to me
yeah you know what i'm saying like
there's a lot of like weight on the
vowels like if you come with some trash
vows it's like what are you doing here i
am telling you
i love you and other people are watching
it so if i come with trash [ __ ] not only
are you gonna be hurt you're gonna be
more hurt because other people can be
like actually with mid
yeah this guy talks for a living and
that's what he came with
and yeah and then there's there's also
the pressure as you're comedian like
everybody thinks you're gonna try to be
funny and the last thing i want to do is
be funny i just was like let me just
yeah tell her how i feel
and then yeah like tell i don't know it
was weird like i really wanted to tell
like my parents
it was beautiful yeah that i just
thought about what you said to your dad
i almost teared up just now yeah it was
[ __ ] ugh unbelievable everybody was
crying
i know mark was crying i was crying my
wife was crying alex [ __ ] he
probably went crying
i got video of of you and alex hair
uh you you know alex harry the guy yeah
he's a [ __ ] man and uh he i got video
of both of you guys dabbing a tear at
the same time
it was really like a grown man in it
like it was a little cold out
yeah that was a lot of sand i was saying
i'm very serious i have it on tape and
at your funeral because i'm going to
outlive you i'm going to play that for
everybody
so they see who you really are like the
kind of guy you really are do you
remember the last person that told me to
go first starkash
i don't know we're going for right now
of my wife oh yeah yeah yeah yeah what
i'm trying to say is if you tell me i'm
going before you yeah we're gonna have
to switch things up you're gonna have a
spectacular death um no i'm gonna
[ __ ]
yeah
i already did this joke when i first
came in but
i know
he's grown up comedian you know dressing
like more girl comedians yeah
on my uh fake honeymoon because my girl
got kovan we had to meet dev and miami
instead
you took a honeymoon say what i know
the audacity yeah
mark's been saving that
and i didn't get a gift yeah you did
what was it i paid you the week you took
off but i worked that week no you did it
i wouldn't come back
sunday
i came back wednesday you didn't get him
a [ __ ] wow
no
when did you really come
[Laughter]
you'll see andrew in real time realize
he's a piece of [ __ ]
you'll tell him what he did and be like
no there's no way i'm capable of doing
it
do you want me to tell you how i
remember the events first or should we
have mark say what really happened
because i was about to ball out on
mark's wedding yeah yeah i remember i
was telling you i was excited too i was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] make it rain on
this little [ __ ] like i'm
excited for him to get married and he's
doing all this good stuff and then he
just did he was like yeah i'm being on
monday and i and i was like all right
and he goes and he just doesn't show up
monday
no no on the flight or something like
that sunday yeah he texted me sunday
asked him on the phone i remember saying
him i was like yo you want to split for
mark's gift like let's go half let's get
him something nice he was like nah i
want to get him something i want to know
it's from me and it's like too much to
take out of like an atm it's like it's
going to be like it's a whole thing i
don't want to travel with that much
money like i got it i was like god damn
what are you gonna do yeah i was gonna
do some damage
and then you texted me on the flight
home as we're about to start work on
this netflix thing um that you're the
co-fucking creator of
right
that you're the co-creator of that you
didn't tell your co-creator that you
weren't going to show up for so uh on
sunday night and then i was like it
ain't christmas
don't you forget it
no and then i uh and then he just said
yo i'm actually gonna go like hang out
in a house or something i'm gonna do
like a honeymoon like kind of mini moon
or something like that and then i was
like what the [ __ ] what did i really say
i said why did you just tell me yeah so
i was upset yeah but in my mind you
didn't come in the whole week until the
next week that's not what happened no
you came when it was monday tuesday we
flew back wednesday but you left earlier
the week before thursday so thursday
wednesday one week bang but also that
was when we started netflix what do you
mean so technically i was paid by
netflix for that week
and me
no
[Laughter]
oh my god i feel like a piece of [ __ ]
i feel r
dav how do you feel right now
was that really though was it really
when you started yeah that was the first
you can see the heart you see the heart
in mark right now right why did you say
that you should zoom in on his face
so you can see true pain in his eyes why
didn't you tell me he's been holding on
to this but hey hey we got to tell you
forever i said i'm just gonna pay you
for that week i think i think we need to
have another discussion in private all
of us
grievances
oh god i don't know
i feel now i feel so bad but he didn't
know he never had a wedding before so he
didn't know what it meant but now he
does now i know what it meant but i
still feel fine with what you
i feel fine with what you got given your
information that you shared me but now
that i know that netflix is paying you i
don't feel good
so i will pay you what i agreed to pay
you for you being a responsible scumbag
i was an irresponsible scumbag that's
from the heart isn't it
you know what you don't even want that
gift
it's it's there's no emotion in it
there's no love behind it
already by the way you took a mini moon
right that's a sacrifice from a
honeymoon yeah that's a little guy
that's a yo mini moon is a sacrifice
don't do this hey
we're just getting somewhere we're just
healing he's already doing our
relationship with just healing remember
when we save dub from hollywood remember
we did that with that netflix special do
you remember that
do you remember that you should be
writing pet and oswald's ig post right
now
yo what a [ __ ] loser paul naswell
what an abject [ __ ] loser that this
guy is right
are we are we moving off of what a piece
of [ __ ] i have
can we talk about somebody else's appear
talking about comics are a piece of [ __ ]
bro i didn't put that together mark you
should have brought that up to
me i didn't put that together oh my god
i gotta look at the amount of weeks
that's okay did you look at it yeah
it's a hundred percent it was what was
the week of your wedding september he's
hurt right now dude no we're gonna get
to the bottom september what fifth get
to the bottom of his pain no you're off
you're off
you're off by two weeks but it was close
i thought september 1st is when we
started now we we finished it was 10
weeks
is what we were paid by netflix for
and we went until the 14th or something
like that of december
so i paid you for those two you feel
good about yourself right now so much
better and [ __ ] you
for right after my wedding making me
feel bad how dare you right after my
wedding making me feel bad right after
your wedding it's been two weeks what
are you a biggest birthday
i gotta give it to somebody bro i
thought you got me knives for my [ __ ]
birthday i made my wedding going like
that that was a great gift
akash was all before the podcast trying
to like get into my count yeah and i was
like i really thought that you felt so
bad that i wasn't making any money on
this crypto stuff that you were just
going to start forcing me into making
money on crypto i was like this is
really sweet i know
and now that i see how much you can make
i'm like all in
so what a [ __ ] loser to chris crypt
like
who would
yeah um but yeah yeah so what a piece of
[ __ ] trying to make me feel bad
yeah i'm a bad dude
i'm a piece of [ __ ]
son that is [ __ ] up we went until what
day the 14th right
oh man yeah i don't want you to be right
i am right
or the 12th or something like that i do
think you haven't essentially started
netflix yet but i don't know if they
were paying you or not
you got it was for 10 weeks so anything
outside of that i had to pay
so you got your [ __ ] gift and you
were about to double up on me
he gave you paid time off
he acted like a normal employer
his gift to you
listen i ain't [ __ ] i know that
but just tell me ahead of time
this is about principles you gave me a
bigger gift then
hey
he's up bro
only cause i told him what i was gonna
splurge he didn't tell you how much you
know i i was like yo it's gotta be big
i'm gonna be honest he was doing so much
i was like i do as much as i was gonna
andrew gonna pay him so [ __ ] much
how do i end up being the [ __ ]
[ __ ] every time that's what we always
want to know
is it me
guys you got a blazer
blaze blazer schulte
she invited himself on
you